that was so incredibly moving i am like
choked up beyond a stunning four-chair
turn had the voice coaches all up in
their fields it's just such like
wholesome inspiring television
kentucky-based mom of two holly forbes
took the stage for the final performance
of the night during monday's blind
audition and blew the judges away with
her rendition of elton john's rocket man
[Music]
a visibly emotional ariana grande
finally hit her block button in time to
keep john legend out of the running
she's so good at this but all four
coaches had to celebrate holly who
admitted she's a crier as the emotional
moment washed over her
me too
that was so incredibly moving i am like
choked up beyond every single second of
it was so emotionally charged i
respect and admire and would love to
work with you and despite being blocked
john offered his praise to holly too we
don't have a lot of four chair turns on
this show it's a special club to be in
just remember that ariana stole the
opportunity of working with john legend
listen we don't blame kelly for doing
whatever she had to do to woo holly away
from ariana because as it turns out
holly's daughter violet is a big ariana
fan she's great i i get it but i'm great
too and i know that there's maybe a slim
chance because if my baby girl liked her
i'd probably go with her too because i
do everything my daughter loves but
violets
i'm really cool too
i'll just remind you that
some children love
too much sugar
or
some kids may like playing with fire you
know it's not necessarily the best true
thing
that episode ended with a cliffhanger
you're welcome america but on tuesday
holly returned to reveal which team she
would be joining i grew up
listening to kelly clarkson
so
i'm gonna go with
the her thing about holly is she's a
little edge to her vocal and i love that
[Applause]
i feel like we're going to be a really
good team together
[Music]
and ari she had some regrets about how
she used her block
i used my block on john because he
provoked me
but in hindsight i really wish i'd used
it on kelly clarkson
when et spoke with the voice coaches
leading up to the season 21 premiere
john kelly and blake shelton said the
target was on ariana's back as a
first-time coach this season especially
because so many of the show's young
singers idolized the two-time grammy
winner
she is hugely talented hugely successful
and has legions and legions of fans that
know how to use the internet and vote
we always come out like you know in like
like i'll go john goes whatever and
blake's usually last he gets the most
screams and and well
and then he used to he used to do and
then all of a sudden he was like can
ariana go before me because they lose
their mind
it's embarrassing to follow her but
that's why we enjoy it see we wanted it
to stay that way because we enjoyed the
hearing problem
it exposes
my lack of celebrity celebrities
when ariana goes in front of celebrity
i think i have a hearing problem
[Music]